happy Friday [ __ ] it's your world
[ __ ] Uncle Joe is just visiting
[ __ ] what's happening it's a
beautiful day to be alive the wind's
blowing the birds are chirping and you
know what you got the [ __ ]
world by the balls all you need is a
little reefer a [ __ ] plan and you
could be the next videocast you'll have
your own [ __ ] Island starve people
[ __ ] smackle make sure they [ __ ] get
back out of there a [ __ ] wrath that's
the power you have you don't even
[ __ ] know it it's just sitting there
caught up and your [ __ ] goatee and
what's my next act is gonna be well I'm
gonna tattoo over [ __ ] dick how about
that going out of the [ __ ] universe
how about that [ __ ] tattoo Joey D is
here whether you bring you the [ __ ]
start up for the day oh [ __ ] will
Diamond go jump around with this [ __ ]
off I let this [ __ ] dry overnight
nightma and put in the car yesterday at
90-degree [ __ ] weather and it's at
all [ __ ] day under the Sun and just
got more powerful oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
finish up this little diamond though
jeah it's already getting me anything
we're Friday's [ __ ] somebody's
got your [ __ ] lunch money in their
pocket when you said that talking about
you [ __ ] the wife thought who gives a
[ __ ] after the promise I falls and all
birds and [ __ ] you talk about the
dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] in the world
but who gives a [ __ ] we don't even need
to talk you understand no need to do a
smoke and ball smoke at each other - one
of his [ __ ] passes huh you come to my
[ __ ] house you get high with me it's
like a teargas session it goes this is
the [ __ ] perennial kanga Wanda or
some [ __ ] like that I don't know what
the [ __ ] you later because it mattered
does it really matter you have these
people what do you smoke which with
which were and they try to be like
[ __ ] hippie like whether what strain
be is slow I don't know about you what
strain do you [ __ ] smoke but I've
come but strain do you [ __ ] smoke
talking to people like that all over the
country to drink this strains are
different they just tell you it's one
thing but they give you a name like if
you one of my [ __ ] spore right over
here Hollywood
science a terrible has a store in
[ __ ] I'm sunset in Hollywood so what
he do for the Hollywood crowd that
thought G would be like you know [ __ ]
Vanilla Sky og so he's [ __ ]
Scientologist can go in there what up in
the Hollywood it's called my death
because they don't [ __ ] around the P
understand me so put that to me you're
[ __ ] Piper's they were Joey what did
the [ __ ] chatter chatter is more
spotted one wasn't I thought that we
forgot go get it you won't shut the [ __ ]
up I know I know
so why are you worried about your
friends huh can we smoke some purple
rain you don't even know what the [ __ ]
you're smoking just shut the [ __ ] up and
smoke and move on with your goddamn life
I'm using that the police is breathing
techniques in my refill ah I'm taking it
to the next [ __ ] level reefer smoke
might not have grief is in my stomach
and my pelvic later on when I whack off
a little smoke signals gonna come out of
my dick before I shoot a load you
understand
we literally to the next [ __ ] level
transform them
I got real class I got a few [ __ ]
meetings and I am performing fine I'm
hanging with the family as my last
Friday at home next week Buffalo
[ __ ] New York helium be there
or be square
Thursday one show Friday to show
Saturday two shows then we take this
[ __ ] circus the Indianapolis two
crackers with my girl move vanish I'm
gonna be [ __ ] around there even now
this man they'll send them two stars
ahead of time when I get there as that
stars already their package you know
what
cuz all [ __ ] around that's why Joey
what's what a smoke another one
absolutely I was thinking the same thing
I'm gonna go and make a little Harmon
[ __ ] smoothie with some basic foods
BAM I'm Sam
a little flats z-coil whatever the [ __ ]
my buddy gave me some some seeds to put
in there loosen up the [ __ ] joints
and get the helmet and tough condition
all right here we go one bleeping one
more
if we do one way that talk [ __ ] about me
Joey's a junkie or [ __ ] stop smoking
and it's nice and dry you wake up you
the company stopping to the [ __ ] kill
thought they I did take it no more daddy
that's my world [ __ ]
scared paranoid bodies the thoughts come
into your mind
or there's no valor of being a Christian
I live your [ __ ] life pray to
yourself who gives a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] Puerto Rican what is
comes that is a [ __ ] my face look at
technical here's the rules don't answer
it
peoples 2016 is the total [ __ ] rules
the old personal rules that's it you
won't suck a dick you will but a [ __ ]
guy with a Batman suit [ __ ] in the ass
those are beans
anyway
if you haven't noticed I'm stoked our
doctor police say it's beep-beep-beep
murky waters with the breathing
technique I mixed it with the reefer
technique and we got ourselves or what I
understand anyway I have a great weekend
uncle Joey loves you with all his
[ __ ] heart understand mr. dog ain't
no celebrity ain't nothing I'm just a
dirty [ __ ] comic that didn't stop
them total these [ __ ] - suck
his dick home - [ __ ] it's being you
against the world in this family Rafa a
lot of people can't say that [ __ ] like
it's us against the [ __ ] [ __ ] these
[ __ ] that [ __ ] nobody gives
a [ __ ] about nobody I delivered them and
then going you back and open up a school
for [ __ ] black kids and teach them
out of [ __ ] water skate or whatever
[ __ ]
until that shut the [ __ ] up
it was to save the world [ __ ] out of my
face number anyway
this time together just to have a laugh
or sing a song but before you know it
comes the time we have to say so long I
love you [ __ ] I'll be around
you know me no you want to smoke hit me
up bang Joey spot that [ __ ] when
I show up my Superman with a cape made a
[ __ ] half house that I love your
[ __ ]
thank you for supporting the church
thank you for laughing my stupid jokes
and thank you for being you your [ __ ]
savages you're not sensitive now suck it
in for this [ __ ] BC [ __ ] games
and [ __ ] I love you [ __ ] stay
black remember in Spanish or you're
being a dork dork money quality think of
my mic that I paid now is getting are
selling my duels I met them in our
language bulu and don't surrender I must
have had that baton a little bit I said
I love you and I hope great things for
you have a great weekend for Joey loves
you I'll see you mañana maybe tonight
whatever we never know I'm smoking dope
I'm gonna dance they black